يُطلق على Libra اسم عملة عالمية بسيطة ،
لكنها في الواقع معقدة للغاية ،
فهذه هي الطريقة التي ستعمل بها
للوصول إليها ، فأنت بحاجة إلى برنامج ، وهذا
ما يبدو أن إصدار Facebook
منه يسمى calibra وعندما يتم
إطلاقه العام المقبل ، فإنه سيدمج
facebook Messenger  و whatsapp ، من
الناحية النظرية ، يمكنك إرسال الأموال تمامًا
مثلما ترسل رمزًا تعبيريًا ، وهذا
ما سيراه المستخدمون وإليكم ما يحدث
وراء الكواليس بشكل أساسي ، الميزان
عملة مشفرة ، عملة رقمية
موجودة على blockchain ولكنها
تختلف عن
العملات المشفرة الأخرى التي نعرفها مثل Bitcoin ،
وإليك سبب حجزها مدعومة ، لذا فهي
مدعومة بأصول من العالم الحقيقي ،
وستتم مطابقة كل عملة Libre بهذه الأصول ذات الكلمات الحقيقية ،
وستكون هذه الأصول عبارة عن
سلة من الودائع المصرفية والأوراق المالية الحكومية قصيرة الأجل على
الأرجح
سندات الخزانة الأمريكية التي تعلم أنها مصممة
لجعلها أصولًا منخفضة التقلب مستقرة ،
فهي في الأساس ما يسمى
بعملة ثابتة وهذا يختلف أيضًا  الإيجار
من Bitcoin ، لكننا رأينا هذه
التقلبات الكبيرة في السعر حقًا منذ
أن بدأت تلك العملة الآن ، وهي
مصممة أيضًا لتكون منخفضة التكلفة رسومًا صغيرة
للتحويلات عبر الحدود ، يقول facebook إنه
سيستخدم الفائدة من
احتياطي تلك الأصول إلى  أبقِ الرسوم منخفضة
لمستخدمي Libre
الآن ، من المفترض أيضًا أن يكون سريعًا ، فنحن
نعلم أن النظام عندما يتعلق الأمر
بعملة البيتكوين أصبح ثقيلًا بشكل متزايد
لأنه كان محملاً بشكل زائد ، وهذا
سيتعامل مع facebook يقول ألف
معاملة في الثانية عند الإطلاق
الآن الشاغل الكبير لجميع  هذا هو
مقدار القوة التي سيحصل عليها Facebook ، فهو
بالفعل قيد التدقيق بسبب
تأثيره على المجتمع ومعالجته
لبيانات العملاء الآن عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالعملة ، يقول Libre facebook إنه لا يتمتع
بقوة أكبر من أي من
الشركات الشريكة الـ 27 الأخرى مثل Vodafone.
Visa lyft eBay uber تتمتع جميع هذه
الشركات بصوت متساوٍ ،
يتحكم Facebook فقط في calibra الفرعي
وعندما يتعلق الأمر بالبيانات يقولون أن
المستخدم د  سيتم الاحتفاظ بـ ata من Facebook بعيدًا
عن البيانات المالية من
calibra الآن بالطبع
حتى ينجح هذا المشروع بأكمله عندما يتم إطلاقه في العام المقبل ، سيكون
بناء الثقة في هذا النظام
أمرًا بالغ الأهمية.